well the cost of basic goods and
services is rising in many countries in
pakistan the price of fuel jumped by 17
percent on friday after the government
slashed some of its subsidies pakistan
is attempting to secure a bailout from
the international monetary fund which is
demanding that the government cut
spending
rising costs spark outrage in the
capital karachi
people have endured two rounds of fuel
price hikes in the past week they are
calculating the impact on their
household budgets
in the last three and a half years the
price of petrol only rose by 55 rupees
but in the past week alone prices rose
by 60 rupees
we strongly condemn it
after petrol the price of everything is
going up the price of cooking oil has
gone up should people stop cooking they
have to prepare food the government has
made petrol so costly that it is
becoming out of reach for the common man
what will people do commit robbery or
suicide
many of the protesters are supporters of
the former prime minister imran khan who
granted new fuel subsidies shortly
before he lost power in april
but the new prime minister shabab sharif
blames the former government for
spending money it couldn't afford he
says the cuts are necessary to save
pakistan from bankruptcy and secure a
bailout from the international monetary
fund
motorists rushed to fill up their
vehicles before the subsidies ended
our salaries are not increasing but
petrol prices are so we will get crushed
under the inflation business is down so
that there are no new customers in the
market
in pakistan as elsewhere there are fears
fuel price hikes could spill across the
economy
you